il y a environ 48 minutes, votre président
a déclaré la guerre à l'Ukraine,
alors maintenant je voudrais demander à l'
ambassadeur de la Fédération de Russie de
dire officiellement
qu'à ce moment précis,
vos troupes ne bombardent pas les
villes ukrainiennes
dans lesquelles vos troupes ne se déplacent pas.  sur le
territoire de l'Ukraine,
vous avez un smartphone que vous pouvez appeler
Lavrov maintenant car il est trop tard
mes chers collègues pour parler de l'
escalade trop tard
le président russe a déclaré la guerre
officiellement si je passe la vidéo de
votre président
ambassadeur, dois-je le faire  pour le moment ou
vous ne pouvez pas le confirmer, j'appelle donc chacun
d'entre vous
à faire tout son possible pour arrêter la
guerre